[Música]
llegó el momento de repasar a los medios
son más importantes del mundo titulares
y artículos de interés y por eso
entonces ya está conmigo el estudio rosa
pérez más seguros a bienvenida feliz
mañana de martes vamos a empezar por un
tema de aquí de colombia un esfuerzo
conjunto de tres reconocidos medios de
comunicación nacionales hablamos del
espectador rosa cambió y vorágine para
esclarecer lo que sucedió en la región
del putumayo el pasado 28 de marzo
durante un fallido operativo militar del
ejército de colombia contra miembros de
las disidencias de las farc en el que
murieron 11 personas y se cree que al
menos cuatro civiles que hay sobre este
delicado tema rosa bueno raúl buenos
días exactamente hemos querido empezar
abordando esta cuestión porque como
comentaba ha sido el esfuerzo conjunto
de tres medios de comunicación de aquí
de colombia para llegar un poco al fondo
de la cuestión o al menos pedir
investigaciones a las autoridades del
país sobre lo sucedido y es que hablamos
de que entre el 26 y el 28 de marzo se
desarrollaba una fiesta en puerto
leguízamo en el putumayo y el último día
de ésta esta popular a la que acudían a
cientos de personas civiles tuvo lugar
un operativo por parte del ejército de
colombia con el objetivo de capturar a
alias bruno un miembro de las
disidencias de la extinta guerrilla de
las farc sin embargo no se logró este
objetivo militar pero en este operativo
fallecieron 11 personas como comentabas
al menos cuatro de las cuales hay
certezas de que son civiles y los
periodistas de estos tres medios de
comunicación llegaron al lugar para
entrevistarse con los testigos de esta
masacre así como también hablar con
militares especialistas juristas y
especialistas forenses para también
poder analizar los vídeos y las imágenes
de ese momento estos medios no publican
las imágenes más explícitas sobre estas
matanzas sin embargo sí que es muy
destacable del trabajo de angie pic una
ilustradora de vorágine que ilustra pues
un poco las escenas que han sido
narradas a estos periodistas por otro
lado también a destacar una de las
acusaciones más graves que hacen los
testigos a este operativo del ejército
es que al menos dos de los cuerpos de
los civiles fueron manipulados estos
civiles habrían sido vestidos con
prendas militares y se les habrían
colocado armamento encima de los cuerpos
ya sin vida es por eso que precisamente
en el cambio colombia alfredo molano
escribe 11 personas murieron en el
putumayo en una acción del ejército con
características de operación militar
legal pero también de 'falso positivo'
es decir de hacer pasar civiles por
guerrilleros al lado de irregulares
armados cayeron civiles inermes incluido
un menor de edad y precisamente también
esta operación que ha sido descrita como
un éxito por el propio presidente de
colombia según las autoridades y
desencadenó en cuatro capturas de lo que
pues iván duque describió como
criminales sin embargo la fiscalía ha
desmentido estas capturas dijo que
cuatro personas resultaron heridas
fueron atendidas en clínicas del
putumayo pero fueron posteriormente
liberadas evidentemente se piden
explicaciones no a estas supuestas
violaciones del derecho internacional
humanitario no en que un en un operativo
militar en medio de cientos de civiles
acaban pues muriendo personas
precisamente civiles no otra de las
acusaciones es que los militares
llegaron vestidos de supuestos pues
guerrilleros de las disidencias no se
presentaron como las fuerzas armadas de
colombia y que mantuvieron a la gente de
espaldas en una cancha en medio de la
vereda donde se celebraba esta fiesta
sin poder acceder a los cadáveres ya
caídos si te parece vemos un extracto
del vídeo que publica cambio colombia
porque pues a cada uno de los tres
medios que ha participado de esta
investigación a un poco narrado no lo
aprendido de distintas formas en este
caso cambio pública pues un vídeo del
que hemos seleccionado el siguiente
extracto
como nos bajaron de esta caja no me tiro
nada por esa cancha y nos miramos no nos
pusieron al sol mirando hacia allá en la
cancha el ejército no le permitió a la
población mirar hacia atrás durante
cuatro horas esta fotografía es
evidencia de ese momento
[Música]
delicada la situación rosa pero el país
también se hizo eco de lo que ocurrió en
el putumayo
efectivamente el país se explica que a
todo este escándalo
pues llega en el momento en el que el
presidente de colombia está defendiendo
su aplicación de los acuerdos de paz de
2016 al que el mismo se puso en campaña
ante las naciones unidas y que pues
todavía el escándolo se ha encendido más
cuando el propio eduardo zapateiro dijo
en declaraciones a la televisión rcn que
no es la primera vez que caen
embarazadas y menores de edad de
combatientes no en relación a estas
acusaciones de que pues una civil menor
de edad de 16 años y también una
embarazada de 24 estaría entre los al
menos cuatro civiles muertos en este
operativo militar también destaca pues
la periodista del país que ya el
congreso de colombia ha pedido una
sesión de moción de censura contra diego
molano en el ministro de defensa de
colombia que se va a realizar en dos
semanas bueno rosa entonces una
situación realmente delicada que por
supuesto vamos a tener dándoles
seguimiento aquí en revista de prensa de
directo américa de france 24 rosa
muchísimas gracias nos vemos pues el día
de mañana con más revista de prensa
pasamos a saludar a nuestro primer
invitado el día